So now that we've decided to go
with a restful architecture for
our development needs,
what about the structure of our data?
XML and
JSON are two very viable options, so
let's compare them side by side as well.
XML was developed in 1997.
It uses identifying tags
similar to HTML and
provides a rigid way
of structuring data.
JSON was developed in 2001 and
is derived from the JavaScript language.
Similar to HTML,
it is easily human readable, but
can be condensed with less
characters to be very lightweight.
Once again, it seems like these specs
aren't really helping in making
a decision if one is
better than the other.
But since our APIs are made
to best suit the developer,
we should use a data structure that
is most friendly to our end user.
Looking at this chart, we can see that
XML started as the data structure of
choice, but JSON has been quickly
gaining ground year over year and
is now the more popular data
structure amongst new APIs.
By piggy backing off
the popularity of JavaScript,
JSON has been readily accepted
by the web development community
as the most common way to structure
data sent across restful APIs.
So for this course,
it's JSON for the win.